>>Reto Meier: Good morning, everyone.
My name is Reto Meier and I'm the tech lead
for the Android Developer Relations Team.
Today I'm going to be presenting the third
part of my Android protips trilogy, Android
Protips 3, Making Apps Work Like Magic.
As always, there will be code, so if you came
to Google I/O just for the Android handouts,
now will probably be a good time to sit back
and start mentally composing your angry blog
post.
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: So I'm old, but I don't particularly
look it because in the world of technology
we don't measure age by the simple passing
of years, but instead by the number of transistors
we can fit on an integrated circuit.
Let's call this Moore's age.
So Moore's age is exponential.
In fact, as we all know it doubles every 22
years.
So let's look at this on an algorithmic scale.
Here it's easier to see that my real age is
closer to 131,000 years old.
That's a lot of time and it's kind of hard
to understand exactly how old that is.
Measuring time exponentially isn't something
that most of us do.
So let's have a look at a couple of examples
to put that into perspective.
It's old enough that I will forever associate
going online with this sound...
[ Sound effects ]
>>Reto Meier: In fact, it's old enough that
growing up my dad used to sell and service
these office machines.
Back then I.B.M. compatible meant these golf
ball print heads which would fit into an I.B.M.
Selectric typewriter.
Now, of course, time when measured exponentially
moves very, very quickly, so by the name I
was in high school typewriters had all but
disappeared and mobile phones had started
to make their first appearances.
Now, they were still primitive at that point.
You couldn't even send and receive text messages
let alone do any of the amazing things we
do on today's smartphones.
So it's fair to say that the only people walking
around with real personal communicators, let
alone tablet computers, were serving aboard
the USS Enterprise.
So what does that have to do with building
magic apps?
Well, we need to put this into perspective.
We need to understand what we're trying to
achieve.
And so handily one of my favorite science
fiction authors, Arthur C. Clarke, has helped
define that for us.
He said that any significantly advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic.
So that's what we're trying to aim for, but
there's a problem because we're all engineers,
so we don't really believe in magic.
Even back as a teen in the mid '90s messing
around with BNC terminators trying to get
Doom 2 to play on my local area network, I
didn't think the communicator badges in Star
Trek were magic, I thought they were kind
of implausible and poorly thought through.
I mean, did you have to press them to initiate
a call?
How did they know who Riker was and how to
get in touch with him?
How did it know whether to make the badge
tingle or to have the ship's voice tell me
that there was an incoming call?
They just seemed to magically know how it
worked.
It didn't seem very realistic to me.
Well, here's the thing, 20 years later we
have the science fiction that they depicted
for 300 years in the future in all of our
pockets.
We have personal communicators.
We have tablets.
It turns out this whole idea of predicting
the future to build magical apps based on
what's out there is really hard.
I discovered this for myself.
I mean, five years ago there was no Android
and three years ago I wrote this blog post
suggesting that it would probably take about
10 years until we started seeing augmented
reality glasses and the sort of voice and
gesture recognition that you would need to
power them.
Now I look into the audience and I see some
Glass explorers already, which tells me I
was a little off.
So even 10 years ahead I was hopelessly pessimistic.
It only took three and we got most of the
way there.
So it represents a real challenge for us.
How do we build apps significantly advanced
enough to appear magical when it takes 20
years for 300 years of technology to come
true when you can't even look 10 years ahead
and guess what may be unrealistic?
Well, Arthur C. Clarke helps us out again.
He tells us to make something seem magic you
need to go past the improbable and to look
beyond the simple case of, well, what if we
can make this smaller, what if we can make
this faster?
As Larry was saying in yesterday's keynote,
develop things that don't exist yet.
Develop things which people don't think are
even possible.
Now, you will know that you've been successful
if you show the app you've built to an engineer
and they say, is that actually doing anything
or is that just a mock?
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: That's our aim, that's our goal.
That's what we should be trying to achieve.
So how do we do such a thing?
We know that developing any kind of software
is all about compromise.
Something which looks great on a design doc,
on a whiteboard, often looks more than a little
different once we've actually implemented
it.
So what we need to do is figure out which
of those compromises do we need to do in order
to ship something and which of these compromises
is going to make our app that little bit less
magical.
Now, the easy way is to look at your competitors,
see what's already out there, find out what
features they've got, what platform features
they're utilizing, what countries they're
localized for, what devices they've built
an optimal experience for, and use that as
a guide.
I mean, you're building this app so it's obviously
going to be better.
You can use your competitors as an idea what
you should be aiming for.
Now, the problem is that is there's a term
for this in sports and it's called skating
to where the puck was.
And it assumes that while you're busily building
your app, your competitors are standing still.
And that's far from the truth, because they're
not even moving at the speed they were beforehand.
The end of last year we asked you guys in
our first Android developer survey what are
your plans for investment in Android over
the next six months?
And more than half of you told us you were
planning to increase your investment and a
significant number said to increase it by
a lot.
So that means -- well, of course, the follow-on
question to that is what are you planning
to invest in?
And we asked that, too.
You asked you were going to make new apps,
make your existing apps higher quality and
you were going to build new features.
So suddenly in the six months you were building
your first version using your competitors
as a target, you have more competitors with
better apps and more features.
So in that next six months if you're very
lucky you're just going to be six months behind
and chances are you will be a lot further
behind.
Now, you are here trying to learn how to build
magic apps.
So aiming for the past, aiming where your
competitors already have been, isn't interesting.
That's not how you create magic, it's not
how you inspire love from your users who have
never seen anything like this before, which
is why it's so frustrating to see so many
developers looking at these graphs as though
they have some sort of magic key to future.
These conveniently hockey-shaped pucks represent
exactly that, the past.
This is the entire ecosystem.
So you understand that of the 900 million
devices that have been activated, those which
are still being used -- this is still useful
to understand your backwards compatibility
story, but in terms of your future development
and what you're building for, that doesn't
tell the full story.
Because if you're sitting around waiting for
Jelly Bean to hit 50% before you start using
those features and if you're waiting for large
and extra large devices to represent 50% of
the market, you will be behind because your
competitors are already building those apps.
So your chances of having something advanced
enough to appear magical turn to zero because
you already have the apps out there taking
advantage of these new features.
Because if you focus too much on those little
slices it's really easy to forget that the
pie keeps getting bigger.
900 million devices, millions of new devices
activated each day and, of course, that Jelly
Bean slice and those tablet slices represent
a much larger proportion of the new activations
everyday.
So we're still talking about hundreds of thousands
of users with the latest devices and the latest
platforms.
And I say this because I want to encourage
you all to create the best possible app for
every user, especially those on the latest
devices because they are your target audience.
They're the ones which have just spent hundreds
of dollars on a brand new phone running the
latest version of Android.
They're looking to have a magical experience,
something which they can use internally to
justify this new purchase, something they
can show off to their friends and say, hey,
check this out, isn't this incredible?
I didn't even think this could be done.
So let's start by having a look at some of
the simple things you can do to create a magical
experience using the latest platform versions.
And I think one of the most obvious for me
is Android Beam mainly because it's so simple.
Most of this is boilerplate code.
Always saying in unresume is if this activity
is in the foreground we want to create a message
which we can send across Android Beam.
If we look at create message again it's fairly
straightforward.
The main thing happening here is we're creating
a payload that's contextualized by the app's
current location.
Whatever we're doing, reading book, watching
a movie, playing a game, we want to encapsulate
this into a payload which we can send to another
device.
So it can be a URI, it can be a series of
integers.
It's binary so it can be pretty much anything
you like.
And on the receiver end it's again pretty
straightforward.
You add an intent filter to activity saying
I'm interested in receiving Android Beam messages
so that I can process them.
And within your activity you're extracting
that payload, figuring out what the context
is and navigating your app to the right location
so that you can then have that experience
of being able to send something from one device
to another by a simple lift tap.
And then some examples, you can obviously
transfer a news article if you're in a news
app or transfer a maps location in maps or
a restaurant review or maybe a radio station
or maybe you're playing a game and you would
like to play it multiplayer.
So suddenly you can just hold the two devices
together, tap them and you've transferred
straight away into a multiplayer experience.
And that's pretty magical.
It may seem old hat to us, but we all have
new devices.
We all understand this technology, but for
regular people this is the sort of stuff that
creates magical experiences.
Once you've initiated a multiplayer game that
way, everything else says kludgy.
Another example, even easier this time, lock
screen widgets.
Is there a more valuable piece of screen real
estate on a device than the lock screen?
Every device with a lock, hopefully most of
them, is going to have your widget when they
turn on -- every time they take their phone
off standby.
And because not everyone has done this yet,
you have that much better chance of being
the widget that they select for their phone.
And it's a line of XML to say, you know, I've
tried it out, it does work on the lock screen,
it's worth doing.
If you've already spent the time building
the home screen widget, this just lets your
users take advantage of it in a new place.
And because it's so valuable it's worth writing
a couple of extra lines of code so you can
specify a different layout specifically for
the lock screen.
Because if you're the first there, that's
great, but you want to make sure that you're
kept there so you want to make sure that that
experience on the lock screen is as authentic
and native as it can feel so the user starts
to think of it as part of their phone and
that's something that they can never replace
with anyone else's lock screen widget.
So it's a great example of where being first
isn't necessarily everything, but it's definitely
something.
It does give you an advantage.
So that's a couple of really straightforward
things, but there's more to this idea of making
magical apps than just using the latest platform
versions.
As usual I have separated my presentation
into three distinct sections, each with a
short animation to give you a little bit of
an idea as to what I'm going to talk about.
Starting with this one.
[ Video playing ]
[ Sound effects ]
[ Video concludes ]
>>Reto Meier: So context.
It turns out context isn't just important,
it's absolutely critical.
To give -- to really get an understanding
of how important context is and how useful
it can be when developing our apps and the
opportunity that it represents for us as developers,
I would like you guys to help me out.
I would like to start by asking you to take
your phones out of your pockets.
I assume you put them away.
And unlock it.
Thank you.
Now, hand it over to the person sitting next
to you.
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: No, don't do that.
>>Reto Meier: It's a very bad idea.
I would never give any of you my unlocked
phone.
I would rather put my home address up on the
screen and my vacation schedule than give
any of you my unlocked phone.
And it's nothing personal, it's not about
you guys.
I wouldn't give my phone unlocked to friends
and family.
A bunch of you are sitting next to someone
who did manage to score a free phone at Google
I/O this year.
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: Wait for that to drop.
The rest of you know exactly why you would
never give your unlocked phone to anyone else.
It's because your phone knows you.
It knows the news you read, it knows the books
you read, it knows the music you listen to,
the movies you watch.
It knows the games you play.
It knows who your friends are.
It knows where you live and what your vacation
schedule is.
All of that information is encapsulated within
someone's phone and that gives us as developers
a huge opportunity to be able to leverage
some of that context to create these magical
experiences where we can transition from building
apps which people use on their phone because
it's convenient to building apps which are
personalized for every person who uses it.
And that gives you that tie-in.
That creates that magic which makes people
want to keep using your phone.
So what kind of context can we utilize?
I think probably the most fundamental piece
of context on any mobile device is location.
And you all know I like to talk about location.
I talked about location a lot back in 2011
here at I/O and I followed up that with a
deep dive into location blog post and then,
of course, there's a sample project which,
of course, contained a couple of dozen classes,
just small snippets of code which were backwards
compatible.
They weren't too complex.
I mean, there was a lot of it.
The location team, they had a look at this
and they said, you know, I think we can do
better than this.
In fact, I think we can make it both more
efficient and easier to use, which is why
it's so fantastic that here at Google I/O
this year they've released a new location-based
services as part of Google Play Services.
And it's actually really easy to use.
Like most Google Play Services, you simply
create the new client, call connect so that
your application can bind to this location
service and then you can start using those
updates in much the same ways that you would
have in the past.
And if you look at that implementation it
actually looks pretty naive.
This is the sort of code snippet you would
have seen in previous years around location
where we just assume that everything works.
You don't need to worry about whether providers
are enabled or not.
And we can't fit more than this on one slide
anyway.
But the beauty of the Fused Location Provider
is that's actually true.
It does all of that for you.
So rather than having to worry about which
particular provider is enabled, which provider
is giving you the best results at the current
time.
Because maybe it's GPS but then if I'm inside,
maybe it's Wi-Fi, fuse provider does all of
that work for you.
You don't have to have receivers looking to
see if a different provider is enabled.
You don't even have to specify a provider
or even criteria for us to figure out a provider
for you.
You just say I want to get updates within
this time frame, and importantly, you tell
us what's more important, within the context
of your application.
If you want to make sure you get as accurate
results as possible or do you want to make
sure the battery lasts as long as possible
or do you just want to trust us and the Fused
Location Provider to figure that out for you.
It's as simple as that.
And then the Fused Location Provider does
all of the work, and because it's part of
Google Play services, as we improve and iterate
on those algorithms, we will continue to be
able to improve the efficiency of your apps
which use this code to improve.
So you don't have to worry about any of this.
It will just magically get better and better.
All you need to do is tell us what the priority
is from your app.
So I kind of think of this as working the
way it always should have worked.
Speaking of which, we now have geofencing
which replaces the much maligned, and rightfully
so, proximity list which didn't work.
Geofencing does what they always should have.
You specify a particular location, a boundary
around that location, and then you tell us
whether you're interested in someone coming
in or going out of that boundary.
And then we send you a pending intent to tell
you whenever that happens.
So suddenly you're able to use location context
without having to follow the user around all
the time.
Again, built on top of the Fused Location
Provider.
So do all of that work.
We know all the geofences sent by all of the
apps, and we're able to intelligently select
whether we should use GPS or you should use
Wi-Fi or some combination or something else
entirely based on the proximity from those
boundaries.
So it's better for efficiency.
It makes your app simpler.
It's better for privacy because you're not
having to follow users around.
You can still utilize all that context based
on specific locations but focus them on just
the areas you care about.
It's about using context but in a slightly
different way.
It's about using the context of your app to
know when it's important that you know where
someone is.
They also had another API that was again talked
about in the keynote yesterday, activity recognition.
I think this is really exciting because it
represents something entirely new and it's
an opportunity for us not just to know where
someone is but what they're doing, what activity
they're engaged in, if they're standing still,
if they're cycling, if they're driving.
And we can suddenly build apps which either
use that information directly, so a sports
or a fitness app which can keep track of when
you're walking, when you're running, when
you're cycling, or we can use it to make our
existing apps a little bit cleverer.
So in this example we're looking at the results
and we're saying, okay, this app is looking
for points of interest based on my current
location.
So if I'm standing still, I can probably disable
all of those updates.
I mean, the buildings aren't moving, I'm not
moving.
So the updates are probably fine as they are.
But if I'm driving, better still if I'm a
passenger in a car where someone else is driving,
I might want to get much faster updates so
I can recommend where we're going to go and
eat.
So you basically want to crank everything
up to 11, make it as fast as possible.
Now we can sort of imply a bunch of this and
add it into the Fused Location Provider ourselves
but it's actually very contextually based
because in this example, which is almost identical,
but here it's an app which is telling us up-to-date
sports scores.
Now suddenly if I'm standing still, I want
to get frequent updates because I'm standing
there looking at the current sports game.
But if I'm cycling, the phone is in my pocket,
we can probably disable them completely.
So it's really about figuring out how your
app works, figuring out that context and being
able to use the results we have here based
on what the users are actually doing to try
to create something more efficient, more magical,
just a better app.
And really, that's what this comes down to.
It's trying to figure out how to utilize this
additional contextual information either to
create a new user experience or just to make
your apps that much more efficient.
So we're talking Google Play services.
We're talking about context.
It would be remiss of me not to at least mention
Google+.
Now, here we have a bunch of opportunities.
First and foremost, we have login.
So you're able to get rid of all that user
name password jumping around, having someone
create a new account for your service and
two years later when they get a new phone
they can't remember having created it in the
first place, can't remember the user name
or the password, having to start it all over
again.
Here we're able to take advantage of the fact
that most Android users are going to have
Google+ installed on their device and they're
going to be signed in to it.
So you have this context.
You already know this.
And with cross-device single sign-on, you
only need to do this once.
So they click sign in, give them the option
to accept and that's it.
Suddenly they're logged into your app on every
device that they own, and always will be.
And that's a tremendous opportunity.
It's something which feels magical because
the user knows that it's their device.
They're not going to give to anyone.
So being able to say you already know who
I am and I'm logged in, makes it that much
easier, more seamless.
And once you've logged in you suddenly have
even more opportunity.
Suddenly you know what the person looks like
and you know their name so you can start addressing
them personally, you can start using the avatar
they have selected to represent them.
And you also get to know who their friends
are.
Now, this is a tremendous opportunity because
suddenly you're able to contextualize the
content you're sharing within the application
based on what their friends are doing.
So restaurants that their friends are eating
at, books that they're reading, music that
they're listening to, games that they're playing.
You can even go a step further and say if
all of your friends are reading a particular
newsletter, maybe you should be alerted.
Maybe that's a trigger to create a notification.
Or maybe you don't want to have so much editorial
modification based on this kind of context
within your app so you use it the other way.
You use it to create a more efficient app.
You say, well, we're not going to suggest
that they read it, but we know there's a very
good chance they will anyway, so we're going
to prefetch the articles which most of their
friends have read so that we're that much
more efficient.
Now, there is a risk when we start building
all of this context into our applications,
and that risk is we're going to fall into
the Uncanny App Valley.
Now, generally speaking the more context you
add to your app, the more awesome it is; right?
So what happens here?
Well, this is the point of inflection where
if you're not careful, your app can go from
being intuitive and clever and knowing more
than you even thought it could into being
creepy and stalkerish and a little uncomfortable.
You want to make sure you're creating experiences
where people are thinking, "Wow, I did not
know you could do that!" rather than, "wow,
I did not know you could do that...."
It's a subtle distinction but it's important,
and it's all about making sure your users
are only ever pleasantly surprised.
They're never unpleasantly surprised.
And that means you need to let them know what
you're doing, why you're doing it and, where
appropriate, let them opt out of it.
I'm not saying you need to nag a user every
time you want to use another piece of context.
That's not appropriate either.
But it should be obvious from everything your
app does and says about itself, starting with
the description in Google Play.
For something like Google Now, for example,
it uses every piece of context it can find
to try to create these magical experiences,
and it's wonderful and we love it.
But we knew that going in.
From the description in Google Play to the
first time we open the app, it makes it very
clear what's happening.
Now, as counter example, if you downloaded
a replacement keyboard and it started popping
up notifications telling you about sporting
teams you liked because you searched for them,
you would be a little creeped out.
Now, I'm not saying that's a bad idea.
I'm just saying if you do build such a keyboard,
you need to make sure your users understand
exactly what's happening with their data.
And that's particularly important when you're
using anything potentially sensitive.
So location information, contact information,
all of that.
They are all protected behind permissions,
so that gives you a really good start, but
it's important that you're using that information
which users have granted you access to use
in a responsible way.
So you're not transmitting their location
information unless that's something that's
fundamental to the way your app works.
And if it is, say you have an app which will
tell you where you've left your phone, you
should only be keeping as much data as you
need.
The last couple of places, not the last six
months.
And if they uninstall the app, everything
should get deleted.
Everything on the device, everything on your
servers.
Uninstalling is basically their way of opting
out, and so you need to remove all of that
data.
And the same goes for things like contacts.
It's not uncommon for apps to want to be able
to look at your contact list and see whether
other people using the same services are their
friends.
But you never need to actually transmit any
of that contact information.
You can just hash it.
You don't actually try to email anyone.
You're just looking for collisions and that's
a perfect example of where you should be obfuscating
that data.
Making it useful for what you're doing but
not useful for anything else.
So if we're trying to make sure that we create
no experiences which people find disconcerting,
we want to go the other way.
We want to create magical experiences which
delight people.
Which segues neatly into my next video.
[ Video playing ]
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: Thank you.
So we want to delight users.
We want to create experiences that are memorable
for the right reasons.
Because if we do this right, we can create
experiences which move beyond people just
using your app and being happy about it, but
loving your app and wanting to use it specifically
so they can experience the joy of using your
app.
And this is important.
In fact, Rob Foster of Mysterious Trousers
recently wrote that introducing visceral elements
into an app will make it speak to the subconscious.
And that's a concept that really resonated
with me because life is about more than just
the things we do.
It's about the experiences we have.
When we sit down for a meal, it's not just
about consuming calories and taking in nutrients.
It's about that experience.
The smell of the food cooking, the texture
of the food, the smell, the taste.
Everything about it is something which adds
up to much, much more than just the simple
process of eating.
It's why we eat even when we don't have to.
It's why we spend a lot of money to go to
nice restaurants, to have that experience.
And that's the sort of thing we want to be
creating in our app, something visceral, something
emotional, which makes people want to use
our app, whether they have to or not.
I mean, we've all sat around, we're all developers,
we've all wondered why is it that someone
is willing to spend five bucks multiple times
a day on a cup of flavored hot water, but
while they're sitting in Starbucks drive through
waiting for it to arrive they'll go on their
phone and write an angry all-cap screed calling
you a thief and a liar because you charged
a buck 49 for your app instead of 99 cents.
Part of the reason for that is a cup of coffee
gives you a lot of things for free which are
much, much harder to build into an app.
It's the warmth of the mug, the smell of freshly
brewed coffee, the first taste of coffee in
the morning.
It's very hard to emulate those things within
an app, but it's that which gives you the
value.
That's what people are paying for, not just
the cup of water but for the experience around
it.
Now, that represents a real challenge for
us, because if that's what we're trying to
achieve, how do we do that?
I mean, there are companies like scent air
which actually creates Al aroma delivery systems
so they can make the street at the front of
your ice cream shot smell like freshly baked
sugar cones or freshly brewed coffee whether
they have that stuff in the store or not.
You can have the scent of shattered reality,
which is, I think, lavender.
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: But until Google nose has a
public API --
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: -- we're going to need to be
a little bit more creative.
So we have five senses.
I think we can clearly say that taste is out,
smell for now is probably out as well.
See what happens next year.
So we can focus on the senses that we have.
So that means focusing sharply on sight, sound,
and of course everyone's favorite, touch.
So how do we do this?
And what are we really trying to achieve?
Now, because we only have the three senses
to work with, we have to work doubly hard
to try and generate that emotional response
by utilizing the senses that we have available.
And that means taking risks.
Because if we can do this, if we can make
users feel an emotional attachment to our
app in the same way that they do their first
cup of coffee in the morning, then you don't
just have passionate users.
You have Kool-Aid drinking fan boys and fan
girls.
You have people who will go to the forums.
They will blog about it.
They will talk about your app as the best
thing in the world, as the reason to buy a
particular phone just so other people can
have this incredible experience.
So this may be a little controversial but
I'm going to suggest that you need to break
the rules.
Playing it safe is not the way you make people
fall in love.
But before you break the rules, like any great
artist you need to understand them fully.
It's only by understanding the rules, understanding
philosophy behind it, the spirit, the vision
that created them that you can move beyond
them.
Now, the good news is that all of that vision
and spirit is encapsulated very neatly at
developer.android.com/design.
And that's where the Android team talk about
not just the practicalities, not just how
things should look, how things should behave,
but the vision that underlies all of that
thinking.
And that's your baseline.
That's where you should be looking to say
I want to create my own magical experience.
And I could spend the rest of this session
telling you how to create a killer UI element,
something your users would fall in love with
and you associate just with your app.
But then all of you would have that UI element
and it would be a lot less useful.
So you need to do that hard work yourselves
and I can get away with just explaining more
of the rules.
Now, I'm not a designer, so I'm not going
to go through all of the visual design elements
and the right way to do you will after those
things.
We have a team of designers which have come
to Moscone this week to tell you all about
it and all day today, starting in room 5 with
the cognitive science and design with Alex
Freiberg.
Great sessions.
Everything from understanding the science
behind how to design things to practical implementation
tips so you can take that vision and turn
it into reality.
So if you thought design wasn't important,
you're wrong.
This is your opportunity to rectify that and
find out exactly how you can make sure that
design is a central element to all of your
app choices.
So what else have we got?
We've got sight.
Now, sound is a little bit more subtle.
How can we create an engaging app using sound?
Isn't that a little bit more specific?
Well, it can be but it doesn't have to be.
Let's take text to speech.
Again, this is pretty easy to set up.
You need to check to see whether or not text
to speech is installed on that device.
If it isn't, then you need to start a new
activity to install it, and if it is, you're
ready to go.
So it's a little bit of code which gets run
once.
And then to say something, it's a line of
code.
Now, this may seem like a small thing, but
it's actually kind of a big deal.
Now, whether it's an app like Google navigation,
which you simply can't use without text to
speech, or something like Google Now that
creates that experience where you ask it a
question and it tells you the answer.
Now, you could just read it off the screen.
There's no particular reason why it should
read it out, but it does, and it speaks to
us emotionally.
We're interacting with it as we would a real
thing or a real person.
Because that's what we prefer to do.
We would prefer to interact with real objects
and real people than machines or representations
of things.
And so that's our challenge, and so using
something like text to speech is that opportunity.
And it adds functionality, functionality which
because it's sensory based is going to get
people addicted to your app.
Say I have two news apps and they both look
about the same and they have the same quality
of news.
In fact, they're getting it from the same
source.
One of them maybe looks a little nicer but
the other one has the ability to read out
my headlines to me as I'm driving to work
in the morning.
Suddenly, I can use only one of those apps.
So by adding something like text to speech,
you add a whole set of new users who previously
wouldn't have had a reason to pick your app,
but now, suddenly, it's the thing which makes
your app different, which makes it stand out,
which makes it an app they have to use.
And they love you for it, because they feel
like you've built that in just for them.
You've built this so I can use the app in
my particular circumstances.
That's the way you create these magical experiences,
by developing for everyone and taking advantage
of these simple things to create that rich
sensory experience.
But that's only half of the equation.
If your apps can talk to you, then they should
listen as well.
And that's where speech recognition comes
in.
Here, we're using intents with extras to specify
parameters.
We're saying the language model we want, which
is almost always going to be freeform if you're
just taking in data that you want to process,
the prompt that you want to show the user,
and the language you want to listen in.
Then we start an activity, which puts up the
voice recognition dialogue and allows the
user to start speaking.
And we get all of that back on our activity
result handler.
Now, in this example, we're going to just
take the most likely result off the top of
the stack.
We actually get back an array list of all
the possible solutions based on the recognition
algorithms.
Now, the system just has to guess, well, which
of these things most closely matches our expectations?
But you have an opportunity.
Because you know the context, you know what
it was that prompted the user to say something
to the device.
So it's a much better idea to go through that
entire list and say, well, based on what we're
expecting, which of those things is the most
likely response?
And, again, you can do something pretty special
here.
You can create an app that has better speech
recognition ability than the platform, than
Google Now.
Because you know what to expect.
You know exactly what you think the user was
going to say, and so you're able to then go
through this list and pick out the appropriate
information.
So what other senses do we have?
I think I'd like to move on to touch.
And I think touch is probably one of the most
fundamental things about modern smartphones,
things which really changed over from the
feature phones that we had in the past to
something which was -- felt a little bit more
magic, a little bit more futuristic.
The first thing you need to do is make sure
the things which you have on screen are actually
touchable.
And that means corresponding to a 48-DP rhythm.
48 DPs corresponds to about nine millimeters
of physical space, which, not coincidentally,
is about the amount of space you need to touch
something on a screen with your finger.
This is important, because you want to make
sure that users get to actually press the
things they wanted to press.
You want to delight them, not antagonize them.
If someone presses a screen, tries to do something,
and something else happens, either they're
going to get angry at your app because it
did the wrong thing or angry at themselves,
because they did the wrong thing.
Either way, you did the wrong thing.
You want to create something delightful, something
which makes people want to continue using
your application.
That means you need to eliminate all of those
situations where something happened which
the user wasn't expecting.
And that's one of the reasons why we suggest
you not put buttons or any touch target towards
the bottom of your screen, because they're
so close to the navigation buttons, it's very
easy to accidentally exit your app, which,
hopefully, is not what your users were expecting
to happen.
It's all really part of trying to create a
more Tactile experience, something which more
closely resembles touching real things in
the real world.
And a big part of that is making sure that
you understand that your users know what can
be touched, and if they touch it, it should
respond.
If you touch a real thing in real life, you
know you've touched it.
It reacts somehow, even if it's just by pushing
back against your finger.
So in this example, we're going to look at
being able to create different backgrounds
to take account of all of these different
states of being touchable, of being touched,
of being focused.
Now, if creating all of these different backgrounds
seems like a lot of hard work, it is.
So you can cheat and just use one we've built
for you already.
So you can either stick that in the background
of things like buttons, or go the other way
and stick it in the foreground.
If you have an image view which he want to
make touchable, you put this in the foreground
and you make sure you have the Tactile response,
the ability to touch things and see them react
when you're touching them.
We talked earlier about creating apps which
worked for everyone.
And we're talking about touch.
We're talking about voice.
So it seems reasonable to segue into making
sure that your apps work really well for accessibility,
for people who have visual impairments, to
make sure that they, too, can take advantage
of your beautifully designed app.
And it's actually pretty easy.
Again, add a content description to every
control.
And it's important here that you describe
the content, not the container.
So saying, "This is a button," is not helpful.
You have to say what the button does.
So, "Send message."
"Add a contact."
Whatever it is.
You have to remember that whoever is using
this can't see your app, or at least can't
see it well.
You want to keep it short, concise, and descriptive.
It's particularly important if you're building
your own controls.
In this, we have a compass rose, it's beautifully
designed and shows exactly what your direction
is.
But for someone who can't see it, that's suddenly
a disadvantage.
So we're going to create our own accessibility
event that describes that content.
Every time the visual elements change, we're
going to modify the output for accessibility
support as well.
Now, to take a step back, if we're talking
about creating something more Tactile, well,
the real world, you can interact with using
more than just one finger pressing touch targets
on a screen.
You can use gestures.
You can swipe things away.
You can turn them around.
You can move them all with your hands.
So I recommend checking out this Android training
class on touch gestures.
This gives you an idea of some of the ways
you can get started to create these more Tactile,
these more realistic interactions with the
objects on the screen.
But it's -- again, it's only really going
part of the way.
Because, again, we can do more than just interact
with things with two fingers.
We have ten.
And, in fact, Android supports that with a
delightfully named Jazz Hands.
I voted for Spirit Fingers, but what are you
going to do?
In this example, we're keeping track of everything
which is touching the screen.
I'm going to go ahead and assume it's fingers.
We know when things get pressed, we know when
it gets lifted off and we know every time
it's moved.
And we know every event we receive has all
of that information.
So suddenly we have access to not just the
location of every finger on the screen, but
the relative movement over time, which means
that we're able to create some fairly complex
gestures.
I'm not suggesting you go and redesign your
entire UI based on ten-finger chord progressions.
That's going to make it a little less intuitive.
But what an Easter egg.
The first time someone picks up a CAD package,
and they go, well, I need this cog and this
cog to move together and integrate, and to
be able to do that, to resize and shift all
using two hands on a single device, or having
two people be able to play a game against
each other on a large tablet, it's not quite
Iron Man 3, it's not quite Minority Report.
It's not that far off, either.
It certainly makes using a mouse and a keyboard
look a lot like a hammer and a chisel.
Once you've experienced this kind of user
interaction, everything else is going to seem
old and backwards.
So you want to create that.
You want to be the app which presents these
magical experiences, these opportunities to
see into what the future of user interaction
is going to be like.
Now, again, there are risks.
And we're breaking the rules, we're trying
to create an emotional response from our users.
And the reality is not every emotional response
is positive.
Particularly if you change things which people
have gotten used to.
Things which people think as the killer feature
of your app, and then you go and change it
or you make it unavailable because, well,
you kind of got bored with it or it was hard
to implement.
They're going to react angrily.
So it's really important that whenever you're
trying to break those rules, break those conventions,
that you do a lot of testing, which is why
it's so helpful that Google Play now has the
ability to do beta testing and stage rollouts,
which means you can create a circle of people,
your trusted testers, who you're going to
push out these new releases for.
These are your most passionate users.
And you can test all of your changes, see
how they react.
And you can use things like Analytics to find
out exactly how that's going.
But better still, you should ask them.
Because a lot of this emotional stuff, a lot
of this engagement is about more than just
how people use the app.
It's about how they feel about the app.
So this now gives you that opportunity to
talk to your users, give them a special version,
and see how that goes before you start rolling
it out.
Once you do start rolling it out, you can
keep track of how that's going.
If you see that your star rating is starting
to crash as you increase the number of people
using the new version, it may be a good time
to stop, take stock, and see whether or not
you're making the right decision.
And it's important to remember, too, when
you're doing these things that not all users
are created equal.
They're certainly all equal in the general
sense.
But they're not all equally valuable to you.
I had a look at the analytics for my app,
Earthquake, on Google Play.
And unsurprisingly, it turns out that smartphones
are my largest audience.
What was a little more surprising to me is
that tablet users were far more engaged.
They spent a lot of more time in my app.
Now, that may not be particularly relevant
to you.
Maybe you don't care how much time people
spend in your app.
If you're selling advertising, you probably
do.
If you're doing some other kind of monetization
strategy, such as in-app billing, what's more
important to you is understanding how quickly
they navigate through that funnel.
But either way, what you need to figure out
is who is your most valuable user base.
Who are the people which represent your key
audience.
What is making them happy?
How do I make them happier?
How do I make other people as happy as them?
You can get a lot of this information from
the Google Play Developer Console, which gives
you a good start for understanding sort of
the broad breakdowns of countries and devices
and device types.
But if you really want to understand that
funnel, understand how people are going through
your app, where they're exiting and why, you
need to use a slightly more robust solution.
And that's where something like Google Analytics
for Mobile Applications comes into play.
Here you can track every action, every button
they press, every screen they swipe, to understand
how are they using their app?
What is their path?
What is the path of people who are monetizing
the best?
How do I optimize that?
Where are people exiting my app, and why?
And this kind of rich information is really
important to understand how to create that
delightful response, how to create something
that speaks viscerally to your apps so that
it appears magical.
You want to remove all the obstacles and make
it as easy for them to enjoy your app as they
can.
That brings me to my final point.
[ Sound effects ]
(Game video).
>>Reto Meier: So a good magician never reveals
his tricks.
And neither should you, because that's the
surest way of ruining the magic.
You want to keep people guessing, asking the
question, how did they do that?
Is that even possible?
I didn't think you could do that.
Telling them how totally destroys all of that.
And for me, one of the most magical things
about smartphones is still the Internet, the
fact that there is this cloud of information
that has the answers to all of my questions.
But you want to steal that magic for yourself.
You don't want people thinking about the fact
that your app is a portal to a world of information.
You want people to think your app knows everything.
And so a big part of that for me is to eliminate
that transport mechanism, make people not
think about the fact that this is happening.
Or to put it another way, eliminate the refresh
button.
Or at least make it something that your users
never have to press, something you can safely
hide away in after overflow menu somewhere,
and then you look at your analytics, actually,
no one uses it.
Some people feel better that it's there, but
they never have to, because your data is always
up-to-date, it's always relevant, it's all
low latency, you always know exactly what
the user wants before they've even had to
ask for it, and certainly before they've had
to press refresh to find out where it is.
Now, last year, I talked a lot about this,
and the big cookie model for transferring
data.
So this idea of bundling and batching and
prefetching all of your information to make
sure that it's as efficient as possible when
you're performing your data transfers.
This year, I want to take a step sideways
and look at some of the APIs that you can
use to really implement some of those higher-level
notions.
So generally speaking, amongst the reasons
to transfer data are client updates, server
updates, there's on-demand downloads and uploads,
and cross-device updates.
Now, for server updates, hopefully, you're
all very familiar with Google Cloud Messaging,
you're using this instead of setting up repeating
alarms to poll your server at a certain interval
to find out if there's anything new to check.
Because it's clearly the right way to go.
You use our infrastructure to have your server
tell our server when the clients need to be
updated, and then we can handle sending that
information to your clients so that they don't
need to poll.
They just get notified of when there is new
information that they need to synchronize
with.
Now, as I say, hopefully, you're all already
using this, because every time you set up
a repeating alarm to poll a server to look
for data updates, Sundar kills a bugdroid.
[ Laughter ]
>>Reto Meier: Sad but true.
Moving on, what else can we do, cross-device
updates, that's another one which is very
handy.
As it turns out, Google Cloud Messaging can
help you there as well.
Now you can create a persistent SMPP connection
between your server and our server and have
your application running on the device send
messages back to our server, using the same
Google Cloud Messaging infrastructure rather
than having to maintain that connection between
your device and your servers yourselves.
This is really useful.
In fact, you can use this additionally to
send messages from your device to other devices.
So things like the Google Calendar notification
cross-device dismissal that you saw in the
keynote are all powered using this technology.
So if a user gets notified on one device and
they dismiss it, you want to be able to make
sure that that same notification disappears
on any other app that they're running, sorry,
on any other device they're running, so they
don't pick up their tablet and have 15 different
notifications which they've already dealt
with on their phone.
As it turns out, it's actually a pretty simple
API, certainly from the client side, all you
need to do is get access to a Google Cloud
Messaging object and send a message.
And you can specify either a project ID to
send it back to your server or a notification
ID to transmit it to all of the other devices.
Not going to go into too much detail, not
going to talk about the server setup, because
I am not a server guy, but Francesco, who
is, and knows all about Google Cloud Messaging
because he wrote it, is presenting in this
room at 1:40 this afternoon.
So I recommend that you check it out.
Even if you use Google Cloud Messaging, find
out all about these new features and how you
can make your apps even more efficient when
it comes to downloading data.
So -- okay, so GMC has taken care of server
and cross device.
Let's have a look at client updates.
Now, for client updates, when you've got information
on your device that you want to send to a
server, there's actually a really useful API
that already exists, if it's somewhat underutilized.
And that is Sync Adapter.
One of the reasons it's not well utilized
is because we've done a terrible job of documenting
it.
And we're going to change that.
But I'm going to step you through the process
now so you understand exactly how relatively
simple it is.
I said there was going to be code.
There's quite a lot of code here, and quite
a short amount of time, so be prepared.
So you start by extending the abstract thread
in Sync Adapter.
This part is really simple.
Extend it, overwrite on perform sync.
And this is all going to be asynchronously
and handled for you.
So all of the queuing, all of the time shifting
to make sure that all of your requests are
bundled up together within sort of a short
time window and across apps as well is all
handled.
We'll even check to see whether or not the
device is connected to the Internet and wait
until you are until that happens.
We can even support things like whether or
not you're connected to Wi-Fi.
So All of those intent receivers that I talked
about last year, if you use the Sync Adapter,
we will do all of that work on your behalf.
We designed all of this to work specifically
to synchronize content providers associated
with an account with a server where that data
is stored.
So think something like Gmail.
So there's a little bit of extra plumbing
that you need to do if you don't already have
those.
If you do have an account and a content provider
in your app, good news, you can stop paying
attention.
For the rest of you, I'm going to show you
a little shortcut so that you can take advantage
of this API without having to figure out too
much about the rest of it.
So you start by wrapping your adapter in a
service.
So this is going to represent the process
that is actually going to run and skewed that
Sync Adapter when we request syncs.
So far, so good.
Next, we need to create an abstract account
authenticator.
Here's where it starts to look a little bit
more complicated.
But, again, this is largely boilerplate stubbed
code.
The important thing here to keep in mind is
the account type.
So that is one of the things we're going to
use as a key when we request sync.
It's going to be the account type and the
content provider authority.
All that's happening in this piece of code
here is that we're going to basically create
a dummy account.
We're going to force a new account specifically
for your application into the device.
It's going to be invisible to users.
It's not going to have authority to do anything.
It's just a way of being able to create this
dummy account that we can reference.
Because it's doing something, we need to wrap
that in a service as well.
So that's going to be the service which wraps
around that account adapter and creates it
for you.
And then we have a little config file where
we define what our account type is again so
that the manifest knows what it is when we're
looking for an account that we can use.
And a bunch of extra metadata which we don't
actually need, because we're not actually
going to display this to anyone.
Next we have a content provider.
And I think this is probably a little bit
more familiar to everyone.
And this is just completely stubbed out.
So even if you don't want to use a content
provider in your app, you can still utilize
this.
The key here is, again, when we add it to
our manifest, we define the authority.
And that's the other key that we're going
to use when we're asking for our syncs.
So now we have all the information that we
need to create our Sync Adapter XML.
So if you already have an account type and
a content provider, here's the bit where you
get to start listening again.
You specify the authority and the account
type here so that when we're going through
the manifest looking for a Sync Adapter that
we want to run, those keys are available.
Then we put all of it into the manifest, the
services, the metadata associated with each
of them, and we're ready to go.
So now we get back to the easy bit.
Once we want to request a sync, we simply
specify the account and the content provider
that we want to sync against, access the content
resolver, request a sync, and that's it.
It will do all of the hard work for you.
It will figure out when it should initiate
that synchronization, it will handle being
offline and online, all of those things will
be done for you.
And you can use this as well to do periodic
things.
By default, it's going to sync every 24 hours.
So you can have it more often than that if
that's appropriate for your app.
Now, there's a few good reasons for doing
this.
But if we're talking about periodic synchronization,
I feel like it would be remiss of me again
not to mention one of the reasons why it's
important not to try and sync your application
at a specific time.
Because there's that temptation.
You know when your server is going to update,
2:00 a.m. every morning.
So why don't we set an alarm so that we wake
the device and perform that sync at exactly
that time.
Well, if you do that, your server traffic
is going to look like this.
That's fine; right?
You don't care.
You're in the cloud.
You've got bandwidth.
It's fine.
Of course, everyone else's app who is also
running on the same device and waiting for
the device to wake up before they do a synchronization,
well, their server traffic is going to look
like this, too.
That sucks to be them.
They should have scaled.
You did.
They should be able to handle it as well.
But what happens when you get your traffic
and all the traffic from every other app on
every device where your app is installed and
add them all together?
Well, then the carrier has a spike that looks
like this.
And that makes them very sad.
This is a bad thing.
This is what makes people's pagers go off
at exactly 2:00 a.m. every morning.
You want to make sure you don't synchronize
anything based on time.
If we're creating something like the synchronized
Sync Adapter we just talked about, that's
going to happen 24 hours from whenever your
app was installed.
So it's kind of pseudo random.
If you do want to manually create something
around a specific time because this just makes
sense, even if you're not looking to transfer
data, even if you just want to wake the phone
up at 2:00 a.m. every morning to do something
else, not related to the Internet, you'll
still have that follow-on effect to all of
the other apps.
So you want to create a bit of randomized
jitter, something to spread that out across
an hour or two, whatever you can handle, the
wider, the better, to try and spread that
load, both for your servers, your -- the servers
of everyone else, not to mention the carrier
bandwidth.
Another approach you can take is to be a little
bit clever and use sort of completely randomized
information.
So maybe it's -- you know what time the person
gets up every morning, so you schedule it
to happen between an hour and two hours before
they get up.
Or maybe you can use the Activity Recognition
and say, look, I don't care, until they pick
their phone up first thing in the morning,
then I want to perform the synchronization
straightaway.
So we can use this API to find out when that
happens and perform our syncs accordingly.
What does that leave us with?
On-demand downloads.
So there's not a lot we can do there.
On-demand downloads need to happen on demand.
But we can be a little bit clever.
We can build all of that into your Sync Adapter
so we can bundle and batch everything together
so every time we're doing a download because
it has to happen, we request that sync and
it'll happen within 30 seconds.
We're going to upload everything we need to.
We're going to prefetch everything we need
to.
We're going to transmit our analytics, we're
going to download any ads, we're going to
do our next prefetch ahead of time.
All of that is going to happen whenever we
do any kind of download, so we're batching
that all, create a much more efficient app.
All right, you've all been very patient.
It's been a full hour.
We started this session talking about how
to create magical apps.
And we're trying to do that in a world where
time moves exponentially, or at least progress
does.
So that becomes a real challenge.
Because we're trying to create apps that are
so advanced that they seem as though they
are magic, something which, if you showed
the teenaged version of yourself, they'd be
left speechless, how does that work?
Is that even possible?
And, in fact, that's really what we're trying
to do is create something that is impossible,
something that seems impossible to everyone
else.
So, hopefully, from today's session, you come
away knowing how to use context to create
these delightful experiences that are visceral,
that speak to us on an emotional level.
And, of course, being good magicians, never
giving away our tricks.
So I'm hoping that when you leave this session
today, you're not just developing new apps
for the future, you're helping to define the
future itself.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Reto Meier: All right.
We are totally out of time for questions.
I'm going to head to office hours in about
30 minutes.
I have something I need to do in between.
But do please join us there.
And do take an opportunity to rate the session,
particularly if you liked it.
If you didn't like it, maybe keep it to yourself.
[ Laughter ]